salut tout le monde
nouvel épisode consacré à un prospect de
la draft NBA 2023 à chaque fois on vous
donne l'essentiel sur un des candidats à
cette draft dans cet épisode ce sera
bright sensabo joueur dohyo state
breyson sabot joueur dohyo state né le
30 octobre 2003 il y aura donc pas
encore 20 ans le soir de la draft 1m98
et 107 kg beau bébé 11e sur le Big board
d'envergure 15e chez via athlétique 20e
chez ispn 19ème veringer un big board
c'est un classement c'est un ranking des
joueurs ça n'a rien à voir avec une
mobdraft c'est à dire que les équipes
qui choisissent à ces positions là ne
sont pas prises en compte pour parler de
Bryson sabot Thomas Mathias salut les
gars salut à tous salut
Mathias on commence par la biographie
comme d'habitude dans ses podcasts
l'essentiel qu'est-ce que tu peux nous
dire sur la vie de Brice
pour une fois on n'est pas sur un joueur
ultra-coté en au lycée donc c'est un
joueur qui vient de Orlando en Floride
qui a même été élu le gatorite player
Florida
dans son état
et qui donc était au lycée de Lake
Island prep et donc qui n'était pas
comme je l'ai dit un gros prospect 5
étoiles mais plutôt un prospect 4
étoiles donc pas attendu comme un well
and donne donc comme un joueur qui avait
faire une saison entier puis directement
partir
ça peut s'expliquer aussi en partie
parce que il a eu une blessure qu'il a
fait rater sa troisième saison de High
School qui est souvent charnière un peu
charnière dans dans les yeux des scouts
etc et la raison que finalement à Ohio
State au côté de pas mal d'autres petits
nouveaux dans une grosse classe de
recrutement de la part de la fac
c'est ça Ohio State qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qu'il faisait sur le terrain
qu'est-ce qu'on lui demandait Thomas
quel genre de joueur quel genre de
freshman il a été
sa première année donc en NCIS alors
pour Brice c'est assez simple il était
pas énormement sur le terrain on va
expliquer le pourquoi du comment
potentiellement après je peux 24000 par
match mais quand il était sur le terrain
il prenait la balle et il la mettait le
cercle c'est un peu c'est un peu près
l'image du coup il a fait un énorme taux
d'usage 32% c'est vraiment énorme c'est
le 10e plus gros du pays cette année
c'est un joueur que nous qui prenait
énormément énormément de tirs sur son
point de vue et prend 12 tirs en 24
minutes il arrive à se correr 16 points
sur ce temps de jeu c'est vraiment
énorme et il score beaucoup il tire
beaucoup mais sur un très grosses
efficacité c'est un genre extrêmement
efficace cette année il a 40% sur plus
de 4 tentatives à 3 points des trois
points qui sont très souvent assisté à
90% quasiment contrairement à cette
jumper à deux points où il est à 50% de
réussite sur cette c'est juste énorme
sûrement de 20% de tirs assistés donc un
joueur qui vit énormément sur son chemin
à mi distance un très très gros choc
Maker à mi distance il aime bien tirer à
trois points en plus sur du shoot il va
pas tant que ça au cercle mais il arrive
à y peser quand même notamment au poste
à ses proches du tiers sur son cours
mais distance ou qui portait pas mal la
balle il était servi beaucoup pour
scorer peu de création pour les autres
on lui donnait la balle pour mettre la
balle au fond du cercle tout simplement
que ce soit au poste il avait des
isolations sorties de petits systèmes
beaucoup de situations pour scorer
défensivement on va en parler c'est un
peu plus compliqué donc il était mis
souvent sur sur moins bon joueur moins
bon il y a adverse il avait quand même
un bon corps donc il peut défendre pas
mal de position et monter par rapport à
sa taille mais donc surtout on le
donnait la parole comme j'ai dit pour
inscrire des paniers pour augmenter le
score de l'équipe de
52% à deux points 40% à 3 points 83 %
lancer France sont des chiffres
élites il est pas dans le
504490 mais c'est pas loin pour un
premier année un freshman d'une grosse
conférence que la dictée c'est quand
même une des plus grosses conférences du
pays c'est solide Mathias pourquoi on
DRAF on draft Bryson sabot qui a un
profit hyper particulier
l'équipe qui va le drafter va le drafter
pour quelle raison très précisément pour
lui faire faire quoi
pourquoi un draft bon bref c'est un de
mes chouchous donc ça va s'entendre
quand je parle de lui mais si si on le
drame c'est pour son jeu offensif tout
simplement pour pour marquer des paniers
aussi dangereux d'aller à la ligne que
sur du minerais-je comme tu l'as dit il
a des stats des pourcentages
impressionnants il est moins spécialiste
au Cercle parce que c'est un joueur mort
pas sur explosif et très lourd tu as dit
quasi 110 kg
il est capable de jouer avec le ballon
en main sans le ballon donc vraiment les
trucs dans une attaque NBA simplement
c'est pour moi c'est le meilleur
attaquant de la draft donc à partir de
ce moment là évidemment qui va
intéresser des franchises NBA
tu veux dire après les
les deux les deux se trop loin bien sûr
on parle beaucoup de Victor chez
envergure on considère que scout
underson est quand même aussi
une classe au-dessus de un soulier au
dessus de tout le monde comment il
marque en fait c'est ça qui m'intéresse
aussi ce qu'il a besoin d'écran est-ce
qu'il y va en puissance est-ce qu'il est
crafter comment il crée son scoring
il est capable de créer son de créer ses
shoot tout seul il aime bien faire des
petits step bagues qui step et ce que
j'aime bien chez lui c'est qu'il a
vraiment une facilité à aller chercher
ses spots où il est à l'aise souvent sur
du migraine il est très facile pour
faire ça
il a un release très très haut même s'il
est pas forcément grand il a vraiment
acheté très haut donc ouais c'est un
attaquant très complet peu de rareté
aussi enfin il peut shooter en mouvement
aussi derrière les écrans
shooter après un dribble en cas de
chaîne shoot il est encore plus létal
donc donc voilà donc ce que je lis à
travers ce que tu dis c'est quand même
un très un très bon jeu de pied un pont
un attaquant complet on a souvent
tendance à dire et c'est assez juste
enfin si vous jouez au basket vous en
rendez compte si vous et les grands
shooters travaillent leurs appuis et si
capable de faire des sites steps des
step bag de se restituer à très bientôt
derrière les écrans etc ça veut dire que
malgré son poids
il a des pieds de ballerines quoi même
si peu sembler un peu un peu pataud par
moment quand il a décidé de créer son
shoot il le crée
[Musique]
Thomas toi tu es moins fan du profil on
va dire c'est toi qui l'as le plus bas
dans la team envergure en ce qui
concerne ton big born même si quand même
au premier tour
malgré tout tu le drafterais au premier
tour pourquoi pour quelle raison toi
comme on l'a dit moi je le drave plus
bas pas pour son scoring son scoring
c'est dur de le critiquer il est plus
critiquer là-dessus il est juste
monstrueux étant adepte d'humidistance
également à me distances il a cinq
incroyable ce que j'aime beaucoup
également c'est que pour un joueur qui a
une frame très imposante il a assez peu
finalement et donc si on aime bien on
lui demande de perdre du poids ça va pas
le déstabiliser sur son scoring même
quand il poste c'est pas un joueur qui
va énormément enfoncer son joueur c'est
tellement un fort chocmaker que au
moindre au moins de petits au premier
coup d'épaule il va directement faire
des effets ils sont défenseurs il est
vraiment incroyablement solide à midi
centre Mathias l'a dit il a tous les
appuis il allait fait qu'il est très
crafty il joue en ballerines il fait des
deux côtés sans problème il a Mathias
Lady également une grosse facilité à
trouver ses spots donc sans avoir un
gros premier pas mais il se dirige
tranquillement il va où il veut il prend
ses spots il est très fort dans le cours
mi distance également il a un excellent
touché avec la planche en la planche
donc vraiment ça c'est un genre qui
guette bucket et c'est pour ça qu'on le
draft très clairement je vois pas je
vois pas autre chose pour le gravité
c'est un genre on le prend on peut lui
donner la balle en main on peut le faire
jouer sans la balle il peut être
facilement assez rare dans une dans une
attaque facilement à trois points est-ce
qu'il a des qualités sans ballon au
niveau des cuts au niveau des
ouais des déplacements pour se mettre
dans les fenêtres de passe etc ouais
c'est un attaquant raciste un attaque en
complet il fait les petits pas qu'il
faut pour se libérer à trois points il
sait sortir de d'écran mouvement il sait
que tu sais prendre son défenseur dans
son dos il est plus bon dans les
déplacements Antoine je trouve vraiment
il arrive à trouver les petites fenêtres
c'est vraiment un attaquant qui sait
comment scorer c'est pas pour rien qui
m'était quasiment 17 points en 24
minutes c'est vraiment assez
impressionnant donc vraiment n'importe
quelle position lui donne offensivement
et il va savoir il passe avoir mettre la
balle dans le cercle tout simplement un
instinctif un naturel pour pour que les
équipes NBA lui laisse faire ça
qu'est-ce qu'il va devoir qu'est-ce qui
va devoir développer selon toi comme ce
qu'il Mathias quelle quelle chose il va
devoir
upgrade et dans son jeu pour pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir
pour qu'on lui donne des responsabilités
pour que les équipes lui laissent des
responsabilités avec le bal
tout simplement ça défense on n'est pas
sur le meilleur défenseur de la clé ça
c'est sûr même si sur l'homme c'est pas
un défenseur horrible clairement il a le
physique pour pour tenir tête à des
joueurs très imposants mais le gros
problème ça défense of bol pour moi il a
beaucoup de mal à suivre son joueur à
éviter les écrans être concentré et
moins focalisé sur le ballon à
comprendre mieux les suites aussi c'est
clairement le domaine sur lequel il va
devoir progresser s'il veut rester sur
le terrain en NBA parce que là même en
NCIS
c'est tellement lourd que ça l'empêche
de vraiment durer sur les parquets il a
24 minutes de moyenne c'est pas pour
rien j'ai beaucoup de fautes donc ouais
c'est en plus de devoir s'affiner
physiquement c'est l'axe de travail qui
va qui va devoir faire
Thomas qu'est-ce que tu en penses tu es
d'accord non clairement clairement
d'accord ça défend sauf ball
personnellement je trouve c'est
peut-être le pire prospect que j'ai vu
cette année offre Gaulle en défense il
est vraiment très très mauvais comme l'a
dit Mathias
[Musique]
[Rires]
bref c'est vraiment compliqué il est des
fois il va être dos à son joueur on
défend vraiment je comprends pas ce
qu'il fait au bol il va être doigt à son
joueur alors qu'il défend un shooter à 3
points il prend très mal les écrans il
est un peu Brabant un petit peu et un
manque d'effort également il est pas il
est pas aussi concentré qu'en attaque
clairement on sent qu'il est plus il est
plus attiré par l'attaque maintenant
vraiment défensivement au pôle c'est
compliqué un bon ball pardon comme l'a
dit Mathias c'est un peu mieux même si
il a les appuis un peu lourds donc je
trouve qu'il peut se faire global un peu
facilement par moment mais ça reste plus
descend mais of ball c'est vraiment
compliqué comme Mathias Lady également
beaucoup de fautes il a été exclu cinq
fois cette année c'est qu'on dit ou
qu'il était exclu en 14 minutes pour 5
fautes donc je crois qu'on est on est
possiblement sur un record donc non
c'est vraiment compliqué au football et
également un style à développer pour moi
pour qu'on lui donne la balle
offensivement c'est développer son
playmating il pas capable de passe dans
le drive notamment il a des instincts
intéressants faut le souligner je suis
pas autant critique qu'en défense mais
il a un corps assez loin dans son dans
son développement et donc des fenêtres
de passe assez facile par moment il a un
peu de tunnel de vision également après
c'est un tellement un bon scorer que
parfois pas oublier ses partenaires ça
peut se comprendre également à cet
âge-là mais il a un peu en retard dans
dans les choses qui vont en attaque pour
ses partenaires il est à une passe pour
deux paires de balles donc un ratio
clairement négatif donc vraiment trouver
mieux ses partenaires en attaque pour
pouvoir lui donner la balle
offensivement c'est une des principales
choses qu'au niveau du scoring même si
j'aimerais qu'il y a un peu plus ce
cercle de temps en temps il y a pas
beaucoup à critiquer et donc le
augmenter son playmaking pour pouvoir
avoir la balle en attaque et j'ai envie
de dire augmenter sa défense pour
pouvoir rester sur le terrain tout
simplement vu que j'ai du mal à le voir
défendre en NBA pour l'instant tant il
est faible of bol il est vraiment
beaucoup trop ciblable de la finage dans
le dans le QI que ce soit des deux côtés
peut-être
du coup Mathias qu'est-ce qu'on lui
souhaite est-ce qu'on lui souhaite
d'avoir de tomber dans une équipe plutôt
de bas de tableau pour essayer d'avoir
du temps de jeu sans trop de pression ou
plutôt votre tableau pour pour avoir
justement des joueurs un peu cadrés
autour de lui est-ce qu'on lui souhaite
de passer peut-être un an à moitié
angélique pour se développer et pour toi
le meilleur scénario de développement en
année
je pense que toute sa carrière son rôle
ce sera de bête dépanner dans tous les
cas
je pense pas qu'il est vraiment besoin
d'année angélique je pense que faut
qu'il faut qu'il tombe dans une équipe
qui veulent donner un rôle très précis
marqué des paniers tout simplement
est-ce que ça existe ce que tu as des
exemples en tête
ont besoin mais tu utilises des gars
vraiment juste en bucket getters
à New York ou des des joueurs comme ça
mais j'ai pas vraiment d'équipe en
particulier mais de toute façon toutes
les équipes ont besoin de savoir qu'ils
mettent des paniers donc
dans tous les cas il va il va aider une
équipe à lui d'être le moins handicapant
possible
de l'autre côté du terrain peut-être
aussi si il est capable d'améliorer son
plan making parce que j'ai vu quelques
petits flashs intéressants même si c'est
encore très possible
mais voilà l'environnement
l'environnement parfait pour lui en tout
cas c'est une équipe avec du spacing et
qui lui fait confiance en attaque ok une
équipe qui n'hésite pas à lui donner au
moins quelques possessions pour qu'il
fasse voir qu'ils se mettent j'ai
Thomas qu'est-ce que tu alors tu as
parlé des moments où il faisait
défensivement au-delà de ça au niveau de
l'attitude est-ce que ce qu'il avait
l'air pas concerné ou c'est juste qu'il
comprenait pas enfin est-ce que c'est un
manque d'envie est-ce que ça manque de
compréhension est-ce qu'il y a des
yellow flags des drapeaux jaunes sur le
Latitude du joueur en fait
non pour moi c'est plus un manque de
compréhension défensive un petit manque
d'efforts également comme je l'ai dit il
est clairement pas à 100% en défense sur
des clauses abus qui va souvent être en
retard sur des closas ou du à son
positionnement qui est assez faible il
fait pas toujours l'effort à senti pour
cent pour aller pour aller closer des
compenser son retard de compréhension
défensive en fait mais sinon sur le
terrain je trouve qu'il avait une bonne
attitude il rentrait à chaque fois avec
de l'envie en attaque il était toujours
en mouvement comme on l'a dit of bol il
hésitait pas à lâcher la belle également
c'est pas non plus un si gros gros cœur
que ça au vu de son talent au scoring il
y en a qui se permettent de beaucoup
plus donc non franchement c'est j'ai pas
de Red Flag sur sur sa mentalité pour ça
reste un joueur qui qui fait les efforts
font en faire un peu plus en défense
mais pour moi le principal problème
c'est de la compréhension défensive
c'est de l'apprentissage donc pour moi
vous parler de d'un scénario en NBA pour
moi c'est pas un mec qui a besoin
d'aller en Chili comme l'a dit Mathias
je sais que même en NBA va pouvoir
scorer il va pouvoir se créer à
n'importe quel niveau tant il pour moi
il a besoin d'un cadre une équipe qui
met les choses précisément
défensivement avec lui pour vraiment lui
dire voilà va falloir tout à fait ça va
falloir que tu as fait la défense si tu
veux jouer en fait vu que si je le mets
sur le terrain je sais qu'il va me
scorer mais pour être sur le terrain il
va falloir qu'ils progresse vraiment
défensivement pour ne pas être trop
négatif vu que même s'il est très fort
même s'il met des paniers s'il reste
aussi faible of bol défensivement ça va
être compliqué d'avoir un impact
vraiment positif sur un équipe même si
il m'a mis des Rangers c'est clair il y
a peut-être un c'est pas du tout le même
gabarit mais un spencer d'ini qui était
un peu dans ce registre là qui était
toujours du plus dans le playmaking mais
vraiment le gars qui sort du banc pour
aller mettre des paniers quoi
une distance d'ailleurs
messieurs est-ce qu'on y croit ou pas
la question à
un contrat NBA
Rocky skale mais ça vaut quand même des
millions
moins moins j'y crois sinon je l'aurais
pas je leur ai pas aussi haut dans mon
board clairement tu la connais
[Musique]
moi j'y crois un joueur aussi fort en
attaque quand bien même il a il a des
gros gros défauts en défense il sera
forcément utile à une équipe donc voilà
moi sur le scoring j'y crois mais il y a
pas de souci j'ai aucun problème sur son
scoring il a pas vraiment de plafond vu
que s'il arrive à rester longtemps sur
le terrain ça mais qui peut mettre 25
points NBA si je joue 30 minutes il peut
mettre 25 ans on l'a vu cette année en
1/3 quand il est sur le terrain il
marque donc sur ça j'ai pas de problème
après est-ce que on lui il sera assez
bon en défense et il arrivera à
développer son playmating pour que
vraiment qu'on pourra vraiment avoir des
minutes pour qu'on lui donne la balle
pour qu'on lui fasse confiance au
fossiblement j'ai quelques doutes c'est
pour ça qu'il est pas très haut chez moi
qu'il est plus vers les vins donc
quelques doutes sur le développement du
reste de son jeu le playmating la
défense notamment rôle il est très loin
d'être ne serait-ce que descend of bol
en défense donc il y a vraiment des
années d'apprentissage donc pas une
énorme croyance forcément dans le reste
de son jeu le score il s'est très très
fort s'il arrive à incline le reste de
son jeu ça peut être un très bon genre
NBA mais ce qui incline elle reste
importante pour moi gros risque grosses
récompense et gros poids sur la balance
br que ça vaut c'était l'essentiel sur
lui joueur do iOS States j'espère qu'il
sera affiné pour les les workouts qu'on
lit en ce moment on enregistre le 26 mai
il était au NBA draft Comba il a pas
fait les les mensurations ce qui peut
être un bon signe qui peut être signe
qu'il a il a pas trop besoin de les
faire qu'il a plus ou moins une promesse
au premier tour en tout cas c'est ce qui
arrive parfois pour pour les joueurs qui
qui se permettent de ne pas faire les
oppositions et de ne pas forcément
rendre les mesures publiques à tous
merci Thomas merci Mathias c'était
l'essentiel sur Brice sensebo joueur de
Ios state tous les autres podcasts sur
les Top 20 à les Top 20 25 joueurs de
cette draft NBA 2023 sont à retrouver
sur nos plateformes d'écouter sur
Youtube et vous avez la version écrite
sur
envergure.co n'hésitez pas Ciao